[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
everybody what the [ __ ] day is it today
tuesday yeah it's tuesday
i think we saw ed wood last night for
like the 100th time
yeah [ __ ] was awesome because i decided
i mean for these live matinees
yeah usually we try to do like a new or
a newish movie
but then i was like dude we have so we
have this huge pile of movies that
people have sent us so
sophie sent us this one yeah and i was
just kind of like and we only do one
movie retrospective a week and sometimes
we
watch an old movie and we want to talk
about that but i don't want to have to
wait for like the patreon
vote to come out so i was like let's
just say [ __ ] it we'll just talk about
whatever
a lot of younger people have never seen
this movie this 1994
yeah this came out the year i got out of
the service and um
[ __ ] [ __ ] assad uh up in saudi arabia
you know i asked him but he'd never seen
this movie i told him about it
okay i'll put on the list i got to see
it but um yeah
it's it's a good movie uh it's a [ __ ]
masterpiece
about the legendary ed wood which he is
a hollywood legend oh yeah yeah
it's supposed to be based upon things
that really happened and a lot of
stories from that crowd of people
that knew him and were working with him
of course
this is all nothing is canonical when it
comes to
hollywood legend and hollywood
lore but i think in general
my understanding is is that in general
this movie is close to the truth it's
pretty much
how it went well what tim burton has
said
and i should note i actually didn't know
this but tim burton was not the original
uh director for this i think michael
lehmann the guy that did
heather's i think he was the original
director but then he had to drop out
because he had to do something else
and tim burton didn't write this but
when he got his hands on the script
he and i don't think i've ever heard of
this happening when he read the script
which was like the first draft
um he's like don't change anything yeah
i love it the way it is
um because the two guys that wrote it
were like film students and they had
been wanting to make like an edward
uh you know like a documentary about his
life because they were big fans of his
and um i think that so what tim burton
said that he did was that
he read the script he read some books
about him and he read his letters
and he's like what i wanted to do is not
make a straight-up biopic i didn't want
to go into like all the dark side of his
life and all that other kind of stuff
like some of the [ __ ] that happened
later on but um you know
i think he had kind of a you know a
drinking problem and whatnot he's like i
wanted this to be
from as though you were seeing it
through ed woods eyes he's like because
his letters come across
as he never talks about anything
negative in his letters he's always very
upbeat
and he seems very genuine and everything
is like kind of heartfelt so he wanted
to make like a more
sympathetic portrayal that still had
some you know aspect of realism to it
you know you know what i mean and he's
like plus i didn't want to like
[ __ ] on the guy because everybody had
been doing that like his whole entire
life and always the worst director of
all time and blah blah and he's like
that just
wasn't anything that interested him you
know he's like i want to pile on and
he's like and he just seemed like such
an enthusiastic
dude like from his letters and stuff
that he wanted that the movie to portray
that
yeah the story isn't about him being the
best director in the world or anything
it's not about the direction it's about
him as a man and
that whole scene and all you know all
those friends and how they
got along and their problems and
everything you know bella and
i get male and nermey also known as
vampira and then like
ed's girlfriends and wives and just the
other people that were you know
part of his crew you know jumping fences
to try to steal [ __ ] out of [ __ ]
studio lots and it's just you know
yeah interesting [ __ ] scene you know
i like a bunch of losers
yeah well i liked this for the same
reason that i liked dolomite as my name
yeah because i really like movies about
just a scrappy bunch of misfits
yeah that are just kind of that kind of
pull it all together you know what i
mean
they weren't losers they were underdogs
yeah that's what i mean
that's what i like trying to make
something
you know and uh trying to get some
success and get some status and
recognition for you know their craft
and uh it's a wild story um
you know [ __ ] and the the blu-ray
that we have has some deleted scenes and
stuff that was cut out and unfortunately
it was cut out
um yeah there's not a lot in there not a
lot but should have been left in there
a little bit more about lugosi
and how lugosi was telling uh
ed that he [ __ ] up by recast you know
recasting his girlfriend and casting
this
new chick into her that he thought had
money that he thought had money
and he gives him some good advice you
know he goes eddie
because it's not the it's it it's not
the mistakes in life that haunts you
it's
it's it's not the mistakes and the
failures in life that haunt you it's the
what ifs
the unknowns that haunt you he goes like
what if i had done this
and uh he gives he tells the tale that
what was it hungary yeah invited him
to go back to hungary and it would make
him like the uh
head of hungarian culture yeah
yeah i think that's what they would have
had a bunch of money and a nice big
house and he goes
but i didn't go because i was afraid it
might be a trick
yeah maybe that they would make because
i'm hungary's
uh most famous uh immigrant and maybe
they would
maybe they would take me and send me to
prison and make an example of me
uh for for for fleeing hungary
and he goes and he goes but maybe you
know because i don't know maybe it would
have been that
but maybe it would have worked maybe it
would have been worked out maybe i'd be
living in a big house with a whole bunch
of money
because it's it's always stuff like that
that makes you wonder
and you know it showed some cool [ __ ]
you know [ __ ] ed
oh yeah yeah but uh bella almost
committing suicide and trying to get ed
to
go with him you know and then he's
sucking around so it'll be vulnerable
yeah yeah
that's in the afterlife we will never
have to worry about getting worse it's
just
well the thing that like i said i love
this movie so much and they
too like to i think tim burton this
might be
one of his like more personal films
because it's not because it's not real
tim burtony
no you know what i mean he wanted it to
look very straightforward be very
character-based he did insist on it
being
in black and white which is why colombia
was like because columbia pictures was
supposed to do it
and then he's like no it has to be in
black and white and they were like yeah
no we don't really want to do that
so that's what he ended up having to go
to disney um disney touchstone put it
out
well the thing about it is it didn't
make money um it only it cost 18 million
to make because disney's like hey 18
million that's like a piss in the bucket
so they didn't think it was that big a
risk
i think it only made six million at the
box yeah it's the movie's legendary but
yeah i think over the years it was a
cult classic got a couple of academy
awards martin landau got um
got the academy award for best
supporting actor for playing bill lugosi
because
rightfully so because watching this
movie you forget that that's an actor
playing
bella lugosi yeah you think that that
actually is bella lugosi i think she's
so [ __ ] good at it rick baker got an
effect too for the
makeup for the for the makeup effects
artistically the doing it in black and
white was the correct thing to do
this i mean i can't imagine watching
this in color it wouldn't have worked
i don't think it would have worked at
all no it wouldn't have worked in color
and um the movie probably should not
have been made
if you were looking at it from just a
dollar and cents that's what the writers
said too they said
they said we thought we wanted to make
this movie so bad but it's like
this just seems like the kind of movie
that wouldn't get made
so the fact that it got made and it's
kind of
they said it should have never been made
in the united states i mean
a country like sweden maybe would have
[ __ ] made something like this
if they know who edward is steak buns
they probably do
i kind of may probably not as much as
here but now that's the thing
if you live somewhere if you don't know
who ed wood is or have never seen
an edward movie or don't really know
that about it
yeah um i don't know i guess you can
still enjoy the movie because it's still
really funny and it's like you don't
but i i just kind of feel like you have
a greater appreciation for it if you've
actually seen
the actual movies that they're talking
about i think the reason why
well yeah i don't think i i don't think
you have to know the movies but
knowing the movies helped it really
enriches i grew up experiencing in
california and they played these
on the [ __ ] saturday matinee monster
matinees ed wood movies all the time
you know yeah there's gonna be you know
at least one or one a month probably
because i think the monster matinee
played two two movies
and it was all the black and white
[ __ ] from that era
i don't know why probably because he
didn't have to pay any royalties to show
it well yeah because probably a lot of
them were public domain or they were
super cheap
yeah and uh i can remember playing from
outer space
i can remember uh pride of the atom
yeah the bride of the monster monster
that was on mystery science theater
actually i think it might have been
seasonal
that uh you know haunted like an
animal and all that kind of stuff you
know yeah yeah despite
despised but they even they even made
like mystery science theater jokes about
him saying like uh
invented his own rise of pipple they
always say rice and pimple because
that's right
a race of atomic superman yeah
what was funny when you watched these as
a kid is that they did have atmosphere
you did
have the atmosphere that you didn't have
the feeling that you were watching
something scary
but nothing ever scary happened in them
no
it's just that you had the feeling that
you were watching a scary movie but like
i said
nothing scary scary happening but you
don't notice that
not scary but an incredible simulation
well there'd always be like
rain and lightning and the [ __ ] and
you know what i mean like the
uh the credits on the intro and then the
credits
on the outro you know the end credits
the the music and the fonts it was like
you seeing some scary [ __ ] but nothing
scary ever happened
no but you didn't notice that when you
were a kid
that's true just you go going through it
you know and bella you know talking
about
here's the race of people you know you
know
that was enough oh yeah i survived that
when i got through that scary movie
what's the next scary movie i remember
that [ __ ]
yeah i mean i've seen i have a whole i
have the edward box set
that has it has a documentary about him
and then it has
plan nine from outer space it has
glennar glenda it has bride of the
monster
and it has one other one i can't
remember what the other one was
maybe it was [ __ ] no i can't remember he
made like a [ __ ] ton of movies i mean
the thing about it is that
the reason that i re that i love this
movie is as i said yes
some of the stuff is not entirely
accurate
but i just really love the heartfelt
i mean this is just such a a warm and
fuzzy
type of movie it just makes me feel all
warm and fuzzy inside because it's just
kind of like this
this gang of misfits in the 1950s
trying to get these like crappy movies
made and [ __ ]
johnny depp plays ed wood
to like perfection yeah i mean he
just captures that set that kind of
childlike sense of wonderment you know
what i mean and it's like
we were kind of talking about this the
other day where it's like i think that
he actually did i don't know if he was
necessarily thought he was making good
movies
i think maybe i think maybe he did but
no he was getting in arguments and he
didn't want to take second takes and he
he knew they were crap he was under the
influence of
bad advice i think because some of those
studios said no we want a shot in four
days we don't give a [ __ ]
and this you know just get the movie
done it's gonna be done quickly
and i think that's how he thought all
movies should be done
yeah well yeah maybe he thought he was
doing it right yeah he's doing it right
because he could get done in four days
so you had to do everything in like one
take you didn't hey you didn't have any
permits or anything like that
well the one take thing i think had a
lot to do with what cost of what film
was
yeah okay he probably only had enough
film you know what i mean he might have
only had
four hours of film or 20 hours of
filming he's like we can't waste it we
can't waste it we can't do second shots
we don't have enough film and that's
probably what it was any money true and
and you know he was trying to pay people
and he was trying to pay people with
money he didn't have
yeah so no he didn't have the money to
do other takes and like i said i do
i seem i feel like he was really at
heart like a good-hearted dude
i mean the thing about it what i was
gonna say and i think i forgot to
go into this because i was going in that
direction but um the thing about it is
that
yes um ed wood and bella lugosi were
friends like both like were close
friends before bella lugosi died
i think the relationship between them is
more based on the relationship between
tim burton
and vincent price you know what i mean
because it
kind of gave me that same that's like
the same kind of vibe you know what i'm
saying because
tim burton met vincent price and then he
got to work with him and he was like his
idol and everything and
so he was kind of like channeling some
of that into the
relationship but i do genuinely feel
like he
felt bad for bella and he wanted to put
bella in movies because
he felt bad for him and because he
wasn't working anymore
and so he was gonna try his damnedest
to do that even though no one really
wanted to
see a movie with bella lugosi anymore
because he was old and he'd been a drug
addict for a long time
at that point when he yeah he couldn't
keep a work schedule he was weak
he's sweet we can real frail they said
that yeah he was 74 i think
which that's not really we can frail by
today's standards if you're healthy
i mean no what's his name jacqueline
nicholson's 80-something
yeah and that that dude's still [ __ ]
yeah we have a lot of actors that are
still in their 70s and 80s and are still
working yeah he's retired but he
some people there's rumors that he wants
to come out of retirement to do a joker
movie
his old joker you know from the joker
from the from the from the 80s
they might do a joker movie his version
of the joker put him in charge
because i don't know if you guys know
but jack nicholson loved that character
he loved being the joker well the joker
seemed like it would be a really fun
character to play
and the other jokers that came after him
he evidently like was
not real approving he liked the heath
ledger went okay
but he thought his joker was better so
he might come out of retirement just to
prove everybody that his joker was the
[ __ ] best joker
yeah he's going to drop his nuts you
might drop his nuts
and evidently you know that joker movie
he he liked it but he didn't think that
was a good portrayal of the joker
but you know that's all opinion it's all
ego well yeah yeah and you know like i
said in there and
the newer joker movie that was trying to
do a different thing yeah like a
continent a
pure comic book out that was like a more
gritty realistic yeah it was like a sort
of
scorsese yeah it was more like that but
um
it still doesn't matter jack nicholson
even wasn't approved to approving of it
oh well yeah what are you gonna do
because his joker was better he's one
dude that [ __ ] might come out of
retirement to do his version of the joke
out of the way kids yeah 80.
i'll show you how to joke yeah now
grandpa to ask me a [ __ ]
if if bella lugosi's dracula was the
first
gothic character uh no i'd have to say
the summonable list from that movie
casket i was going to say a lot of
silent movies never silent movies
yeah what was that 1922 yeah twenty
three something done in a real baja
style
you know they had real good sets it was
a silent movie real long
uh not interesting by today's standards
kind of boring
uh but the imagery was really good in it
and uh no i'd say he's probably pretty
good and i'm telling you right now
that i saw a silent adaptation of
the fall of the house of usher from 1921
i want to say yeah and one of the
characters in that
straight up looked like susie sue so
you know had all the black makeup and
the yeah because i feel like the silent
era i think that was where like a lot of
goff the goth look came from yeah i
think so too
like the eye makeup eye makeup and yeah
because that's what they have like in
the
you know in the silent movie era that's
kind of what everybody looked like with
all the heavy makeup and everything all
the clothes being kind of black and
white
yeah you know yeah that just reminded me
of like
because i'm trying to think of all my
favorite uh
scenes from ed wood the movie and there
are so many like pretty much the whole
thing is my favorite scene
but i just thought of that when you said
about the black and white movies and
there's that one scene where
where loretta is holding up the two
dresses it's like which dress you want
better he asks like the cameraman or the
cinematographer or whatever
and he's like uh which one's the green
one i can't tell and he's like what are
you talking about he's like
i mean i can't tell the difference i'm
colorblind
but i kind of like the dark grey one so
it's like his [ __ ] camera man [ __ ]
like that was
speaking of uh the joker and goth stuff
um the joker
actually that character cesar romero's
version and i think the comic book
character too
was based on i think it was a silent
movie about a series yeah the man who
laughs
the man who laughs and if you see
photographs of that guy
it looks just like the joker that's it
that's actually a good flick
uh conrad conrad vite i think is in that
i saw
that one and he's in another one called
the hands of orlak which is also really
good
um 1920s from the 1920s yeah
um but yeah yeah so if you see pictures
and i've actually seen pictures of that
of the man who laughs like out of
context because i don't know if people
know that that's from a movie
yeah but that's where the guy that drew
the joker like
drew that character that's where he got
the yeah a lot of people don't realize
how incomplete the catalog is when it
comes to
movies especially the silent era a lot
of them are gone
we have the titles but they just don't
have the movies anymore yeah they got
lost well
as i said because a lot of them were on
that silver nitrate stock and they just
[ __ ] spontaneously combined
and there's no um there's no original
version of phantom of the opera i think
they have about three or four versions
and all of them are just
reha re-edits and rehashes of other
versions of that movie they just kept
they kept putting it together because
that that movie came out during a time
at the end of silent movies at the
beginning of talkies
so it started off as silent film and
then they had two or three versions of
the silent film and then they converted
then they converted over to talky and
they evidently
smashed the silent versions together and
redid some [ __ ]
and added some stuff but other things
were lost most of the versions of
of uh phantom of the opera all [ __ ] up
there's a it starts with a scene with a
guy in a cave talking but there's no
you can't hear what he's saying there's
no audio for it yeah and it was some
kind of monologue that started the thing
nobody knows what the bottle log was
it's weird and then they ended up
colorizing it too
i think i think in a weird primitive
color like a hand done color
yeah they used to do that back in the
day because i saw one i saw a silent
movie [ __ ] man which one was it i think
it was the red spectre
and um it's kind of like one of those
real early like what they call trick
movies it's like it doesn't have a plot
as such it's not narrative
but it's almost kind of like if you went
to see a stage show and there was like
magicians it was like all these like
camera tricks
that they did and um they had that and
at one point
there was i'm pretty sure it was the red
spectre but there was kind of like all
these jars with like these little tiny
women in them
and then like the whole thing goes red
and i think that back in the day
i think maybe i don't know if they had
to paint the film stock or if they just
had like some kind of filter they had a
layover i think they had to paint it
would they not yeah they was painted by
hand yeah i think it was
the uh but you can go on youtube and
see a bunch of hand or handmade
documentaries or user made documentaries
trying to get down to the bottom of what
the original
phantom of the opera movie was they
don't they're not really sure
yeah and louie's pointing out too that
london after midnight is probably the
most famous lost movie
yeah yeah there's a lot of other ones
too like i said i i saw one that was
russian and i think it's called what was
it called the portrait or
something like that and i think there's
only six or eight minutes of it is all
that's left
and it seemed like really intriguing you
know what i mean it's like this guy and
he finds like a
painting of a creed old dude in a uh
like a thrift shop or something and he
takes it home and then like the guy
starts like popping out of the painting
and stuff
and i would have liked to have seen that
whole movie but unfortunately
it's weird you can't track down what
what history was like when all the
people involved were dead
yeah you know you don't know who to ask
they're all dead yeah
yeah so much stuff is lost yeah it's
gone and then kind of
a subject kind of on the side of this uh
dr carrier was talking about roman
history
how it's the same way with roman history
we don't know what the level of
technology was
anything that would have given us a peek
into what their level of technology was
was that
over the centuries erased by the church
they wouldn't because they wouldn't
allow
certain discussions of natural science
and things
you know not all at once it's just a
process of elimination yeah
every 100 years a certain amount of
books got destroyed because it mentioned
atheism
or atheistic ideas from ancient rome and
natural science
a lot of that [ __ ] 300 bc might have
been damn near industrial
right like pre-industrial society you
know what i mean like 1800s
yeah there's we don't know there's
really no way of knowing it seems to be
more advanced than we give it credit for
that's true and there's no way of
knowing it's weird yeah
so long ago there's no way of knowing
weird but yeah so
uh all right so let's get back to
talking about edward yeah all right so
um
so yeah so a lot of the things that i
love about this movie like i said i
don't know
i'd be interested to know if somebody
that had never seen
an actual edward movie and then watched
this one
is it as entertaining like what did you
think of it you know what i mean because
as i said i don't think you need to but
it really does help because
you know it kind of goes from scene to
scene i think it starts out in the early
50s right
where he just has this you know he's
doing this play and it's terrible
and then he they kind of go into
how he got to direct glenn or glenda
which was his first film because he's a
transvestite i don't know
if uh you know everybody here probably
knows that but i didn't know if anybody
knew that
so um the the scene with him
and that producer george weiss like in
the office because george weiss is like
oh we want to make a movie about the
christine jorgensen story he was like a
you know a trans person in the 50s
who was trying to get a gender
reassignment
and so they wanted to make a movie
called that but then they didn't get the
right so they just had to call it i
changed my sex
so then ed wood was like hey i'm a
transvestite so i'm like the person that
should do that
and then he so he turns it into glen or
glenda which was almost kind of like
ed wood was really kind of ahead of his
time because the movie that he made
doesn't make a goddamn bit of sense
because he had met bella lugosi just by
chance
and so he wanted to put bella lugosi in
the movie so he makes
bella lugosi just like this puppet
master kind of character
yeah like a wraparound story like in a
wrap around he's like
you know what i mean so he has all that
going on has [ __ ] all to do with the
rest of it there's all this crazy
like stock footage in there like
buffalo's running like people
it's just it doesn't make artillery
attacks and ed wood is in it
himself and he's you know and he plays
glenn and glenda
so he's it's almost kind of like an a a
quasi documentary
about transvestism and about like
acceptance for it which like i said
that's very ahead of its time
this was like the early 50s that he made
this yeah yeah
it was funny because he was
ed ed was a veteran all right yeah
he was a paratrooper of some sort i
don't know which division he was from
and he was fighting the japanese
he was on the island of pelelu which is
that's
if memory serves it was pelulu i think
it was and
um which was one of the most savage
[ __ ]
battles of all times um that was the one
where they were running around [ __ ]
cutting people's heads off and
guys were putting enemy heads on around
their fighting positions
it's on top of the jeeps it was it was
slaughter
um on both sides they killed them all
they killed basically all the japanese
on the island
uh it was like a [ __ ] regiment of
them anyway
he was on that and he claims that he was
on that attack wearing [ __ ]
women's underwear underneath his uniform
yeah and they say and he says that in
the movie too he tells george
he wasn't afraid of getting killed he
was afraid of getting wounded
and that them [ __ ] the medics [ __ ]
turned his clothes off and finally he
had a bra of panties on
yeah he says that yeah and that is that
is the story that's how the story goes
that's he used to sell that story yeah
and he he grew up with this because his
mother
dressed him up as a girl when he was a
little kid
and he was because he wanted a daughter
yeah and well i think it was kind of a
comforting thing
and when he was under stress he would go
back to putting on female clothing
i think it chilled him out yeah because
yeah they show that a lot in this movie
too like every time he gets upset about
something like
that and angora and [ __ ] like you know
like when he has
to do plan nine from outer space he has
to get that money from the baptist
you know what i mean the church and
they're like that's a whole funny thing
like they're trying to interfere and
stuff because it's their money
they all have to get baptized and all
this other kind of [ __ ] but they're kind
of trying
hey we need to put this guy in the movie
and hey we can't call it grave robbers
from outer space which is what it's
supposed to be called
and he was just getting like so [ __ ]
stressed out about it and he goes in the
other he goes down to the
you know he goes in the other room and
puts on like the angora sweater and the
wig and the pumps and everything like
that
and then he's yeah and you know the guys
that worked with him were like
are you uh are you gay you know he's
like no no i'm all man i'm oh man i like
women
it's just you know when i'm upset i get
so when he was under
a it was just he was trying he was a
dude
who he had this little quirk and
when he got under when he was under
pressure he wanted to put on women's
clothes and
[ __ ] made him probably reminded him
of
being with his mom being a boy with his
mom probably kind of like what do you
call it
infantilism probably like a retreat into
individualism
yeah i don't know if it's so much that
it was just something that he associated
with
comfort safety or comfortable yes well
that's what i'm saying retreat into
interfaith it's about the same thing
yeah comfort you know going back to the
womb
is what basically oracle says hey cross
dressing sounds a lot better than some
options for dealing with stress
right i mean if everybody could just do
that when they were that would be like
much better
so when he was making this movie he was
trying to
and you could see it in the in the movie
ed wood he's trying to bring about
public awareness
that that he wasn't
that people that did this were not bad
people they just had this issue
yeah and so like i said he was way ahead
of his time yeah in that regard it's a
terrible movie and it doesn't make a
goddamn benefit doesn't make any sense
but and you can tell that it's
autobiographical right
you know he's writing about he actually
kind of wrote it
to sort of i don't know how close to the
truth this is but to sort of sideways
like tell his
girlfriend at the time dolores fuller um
that he was a transvestite because she
didn't know yeah um
so that was like his offhand wave
because he was too scared to tell her
directly yeah now here's another
weird aspect about [ __ ] ed ed was
[ __ ]
he was super patriotic he would have
been kind of considered to be right-wing
by today's standards i think you know he
was [ __ ] all about america
apple pie red white and blue and
chevrolet
and wearing angora sweaters and being a
transvestite that was all part
of [ __ ] the freedoms of being
american
and in these wraparound stories you know
he's always talking about the
authorities he deferred to authority and
government
authority a lot it was just part of his
nature i think it's because
coming out of world war ii the guys were
very much oriented towards nation and
government authority
and even the dialogue in the movies i
can remember them as as a kid and they
talked about them here in the movies
they're always talking about how the
author the authorities have now
discovered that you are speaking that
you are speaking the truth
so now everything's official so
everything had he
he and he had weird ways where if he
wanted to talk about
a subject that was kind of taboo like
pornography like pornography
he had to look at it from their point of
view of the authorities yeah the
authorities don't like this
so we're going to talk about it and that
means we can do it yeah and that way you
can show it
yeah yeah which is what he did in the
sinister urge
yeah which like i said i i kind of feel
like he makes the movie it's kind of a
way of having your cake and eating it
yeah
is that you can show a movie with all of
these kind of like salacious
[ __ ] in there although from today's
standard of the sinister yeah it's just
like
chicks and baggy swimsuits it's not
pornography but um
but you can show that but you can also
like tisc at it at the same time yeah
but he also from what i remember he
played games with that that's what i'm
saying
that it was a way of getting around you
could tell that he didn't really think
it was a
problem no of course he didn't think it
was probably he was just trying to get
around
but he had to kind of he was constantly
trying to get put little caveats yeah
this this this porn's going on
the government doesn't like it and you
need to protect yourself from it but
let's talk more about porn
yeah you know what i mean well the whole
talk more about the whole basis of the
sinister urge was that
the porn was making this one guy
who was you know an assistant to the
woman that was producing the porn
was making him essentially a serial
killer yeah which is there's
seriously see the sinister urge that one
was on mst as well
and um the woman that runs the porn ring
is amazing i love her and i love her
outfits
she is just the craziest she's like one
of those
you know like back in the day when they
had those like the the women they
were like hard drinking and hard smoking
and she always wore like super super
fancy like
shiny prom dresses and she kind of
talked like that and
it was so awesome i was like she's like
my spirit animal i love that
but yes watch the mystery science
theater episode because it's like
delightful
but uh that movie is [ __ ] crazy i
just think it's i just think it was
funny that
ed was always worried about what the
about the authorities point of view in
society
and he was trying to make some
educational [ __ ] he was trying to make
it educational
but you could also i could also sense
that he was trying to butter up people
too
yeah this ain't no big deal yeah just
because the authorities say it is
you know porn does not make serial
killers quite the opposite
that that releases a lot of [ __ ] yeah
i think it's tension off
yeah i think it's the opposite yeah i
mean there is data showing that as soon
as the internet became widespread
crime [ __ ] started to [ __ ] fall
through the [ __ ] floor crime
the crime rate declined and it was
because people [ __ ] fight on the
internet instead of fighting
face to face like i said so you're now
kind of releasing
a lot of pressure and same thing with
the
porn the availability of porn sexual
assaults
went down didn't go up went down well
especially nowadays because you can find
pretty much whatever your kink is you
can find
that and you don't have to go anywhere
to get it you can just sit on your couch
in cells and [ __ ] that are sexually
frustrated they're too busy beating off
they don't [ __ ] they don't have the
energy left
they don't have an energy though can we
take a moment to a pre i mean because
obviously
um johnny depp is amazing in this
obviously martin landau is [ __ ]
amazing in this as bella goes
like i said i saw this in the theater
when it came out because i was super
into
ed wood movies and all that kind of
stuff so i saw in the theater and came
out i guess well not a lot of people did
sadly
but um you know martin landau amazing i
thought
i kept forgetting that that wasn't
actually bella lugosi can we take a
moment to appreciate bill murray
as bunny breckenridge because that
it said it's a small role but
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] i mean just his
[ __ ] delivery
the facial expression i mean bill murray
is [ __ ] rad anyway
but just when they're all at that
[ __ ]
the [ __ ] church service before they
all get baptized because they'll have to
get baptized so the
you know so the baptist will pay for
their for the movie and they're all
sitting in the back
and uh you know bella lugosi has died
and they
um are putting this dude who's a
chiropractor
of uh you know ed's girlfriend at the
time kathy
and they're putting him in the movie but
he doesn't look anything like bella
lugosi and he's like way taller than him
and all this other kind of [ __ ]
so it's like he has to put something
over his face you can't show his show
his face
and then so he's trying to do the voice
like at the back of the pew
you know trying to but i will suck your
blood and suck your blood or whatever
and then bill murray like turns to me
goes
let's hear you call boris karloff
yeah yeah yeah
all these [ __ ] funny inside jokes
from the [ __ ] all the friends another
thing that was cool is that they added
a scene where ed meets um
orson welles yeah oracle just brought
that up vincent donafrio plays him
yeah and i don't know if that happened
in real life no it didn't it didn't yeah
it
sounded kind of contrived yeah uh but
it's in there because
a guy like uh ed wood would have [ __ ]
probably worshipped orson welles because
yeah he had a lot in common in certain
ways
uh they were both kind of independent
outside the studio system
they could direct write direct and
[ __ ] produce their own movies
and bring them to market with their own
money although orson welles i think only
did that once or maybe twice but i don't
think he did it
but citizen kane was made that way which
is when he was 26 years old yeah which
is like you know
and after that everybody was like oh
okay it would be a masterpiece i've
never seen it but it's supposed to be a
masterpiece
yeah um so ed would have
would have seen would have wanted to see
himself like an orson welles type figure
but it just didn't it didn't have a
talent
but no sadly yeah he answered but he had
he had the drive he wanted to be you
know
i think a lot of what edward did is just
because he wanted to be active
active he wanted to be in movies
and he was surrounded himself with a
bunch of other people that wanted to be
in movies and wanted to work
but really they weren't getting any work
you know this is the only work that they
could get
and this is a way of being hollywood
adjacent
yeah you could say i'm a director you
know
you know you know where you don't not
director for a big studio
you know but you're an independent
director so
that's what i think it was about and um
he got into this with bad habits
according to the movie
uh the bad habit of trying to shoot a
movie in four days [ __ ] terrible
of not knowing much about the technical
aspects of how to shoot a film
yeah or how to write scripts yeah how to
write dialogue
um he just
was he was not he didn't pay attention
to detail
he just wrote the [ __ ] up fast and let's
do it it'll be fine the kids won't
notice
it's like that that's basically what he
said i mean there's one scene and play
where they're at the end where they're
shooting plant nine from outer space
and um tor johnson played by george the
animal steel in the movie
he gets stuck coming out of the grave
because he's so big
and like the two guys playing cops have
to come and like help him out of the
thing
and he's just like it's fine we're not
doing another take we'll just leave it
yeah and it's you know it's you you can
see it if you watch the actual plan on
from outer space i mean you can see like
the
gravestones are obviously cardboard um
you know
torah johnson like walks into the wall
like when he's going through the door at
one point you can tell it's just like a
cardboard like a set
you know what i mean like he runs his
elbow into the or his shoulder into the
door
like you can tell [ __ ] like that and
they just didn't he just didn't fix it
tor johnson was great though in [ __ ]
the the land that time forgot remember
that british movie
that's right yeah but i've forgotten the
evil samurai it's almost kind of like a
conan movie in a certain way
he was thinking about commander yeah
a [ __ ] nazi yubo ends up kind of like
in a hollow earth type situation where
there's
it's still primitive times i need to see
that one again that's a good movie i
like that movie a lot
yeah well torah johnson was in some
other [ __ ] too he was in um
goddamn what was that coleman francis
movie that was also on
uh beast of yucca flats yeah yeah that
was also
and i would argue that
coleman francis movies are way worse
than
edward movies because coleman francis
movies
i think he only made three and they were
all on mystery science theater
those beastie yucca flats uh the
skydivers
and red zone cuba and
but his movies are kind of boring
edwards movies are not boring
not at all they are just so bad like the
dialogue is so batshit
and it's just so fun like watching
these ridiculously cheap yeah
sets like you know like ufo is obviously
made of like paper plates
um you know an airplane thing that's
obvious just like two chairs with like a
piece of
wood [ __ ] [ __ ] tons of stock footage
that just doesn't [ __ ] make it so
[ __ ] great
blows running by and [ __ ] you know so
you know army footage of them [ __ ]
shooting [ __ ]
artillery shells off that you know
you're like what the where is this we're
back in korea
you know it must be california but it's
obviously [ __ ] footage from korean
war
i mean he did the one okay so when they
were doing the end of bride of the
monster
where dr off gets eaten by the octopus
because and he only had that idea
because
there was stock footage of an octopus
and he wanted to use it so he's like
well we need some
you know footage of above ground like
not underwater to match with the octopus
footage
so they went into this other studio they
broke in
and they stole the octopus but they
didn't take the motor so it just kind of
sat there
so it just sits there in the thing and
then it's like a night shoot and poor
bella lugosi
in the movie he's just kind of like um
well we don't have the motor and the
arms don't move so you just have to like
lay there in the middle of it and like
pull the arms around make it look like
he's killing you
and it's like this freezing cold water
like in the middle of the day
so a lot of some of the stuff that he
did you know it kind of made sense in
the context of the time yeah
i mean his first job with glenda glenda
he's working for a studio that just
makes [ __ ]
basically yeah they just make [ __ ] and
they know they make [ __ ] movies they
just make exploitation movies
right and they straight up tell them
look we don't give a [ __ ]
you just have to be confident it has to
be a [ __ ] movie has to be what seven
reels long
it has to be you have to shoot the [ __ ]
in four days for as little
as money as possible and we'll sell this
piece of [ __ ] to the
yeah because they already had a poster
and so i mean because these posters came
before the movies
yeah well because it's like uh you know
when when he meets with uh george weiss
at the beginning and he's just like do
you have a script and jordan's like [ __ ]
no
got a poster though and you know this is
50s yeah late 50s and
not everybody had a television set then
you know yeah that's true
experimentally early 50s yeah and what
was on tv wasn't any good it's usually
like
live variety shows so they weren't
movies
uh sometimes they would replay old
movies but that's not what mostly the
local networks were showing
so during the daytime in these theaters
they would
play you know matinees and they would
kind of targeted to
kids yeah and that's really who was
these these movies were intended for
and you know when they should go to the
grand openings you see it's just a bunch
of kids running around throwing [ __ ]
popcorn jumping up and grabbing
[ __ ] vampires titties
they're just rowdy kids and they
probably did
the audience at the time probably didn't
give a [ __ ] well like i said i didn't
cost anything to go to these movies yeah
their version achieved like a nickel or
something and it was just like
it'd be like sitting in front of the
tube watching tv that so
you could get away with it it was
probably wasn't
as out of place looking back in the 50s
as it is today
that's what i was gonna say because i
feel like i've seen
other movies from the 50s yeah well one
i've seen worse ones than ed wood movies
at least those are entertaining
yeah um i've seen other good movies from
the 50s
where the special effects and stuff
weren't much better than
one level i'm just there wasn't a huge
chasm
well that dude that dude from um
that dude from arkansas that did the
[ __ ] bigfoot movies with the boggy
creek movies yeah yeah
charles b pierce yeah his movies weren't
great either technically they were a lot
better
and the cast and the dialogue was a lot
better
but they weren't that much better than
an edward movie
you know they were both [ __ ]
ridiculous dollar for dollar
and probably ed wood might beat him
because it depends on what mood you're
in because sometimes now the first boggy
creek
was actually a pretty decent movie um
and he also made the town that dreaded
sundown the original
and that was a pretty decent one except
for the
uh you know the comic relief cop which
he played actually i think they could
have done without that
but uh boggy creek 2
is so awful that it goes all the way
around and becomes awesome again well
it's like mano's hands of fate
yeah mano's hands of fate i think is
worse than an
edward flick oh yeah but you just
[ __ ]
laugh your ass off watching that thing
and you don't laugh
so much at an edward movie i don't know
i do yeah but not as much
yeah to me mano's hands of fate is even
more ridiculous
manos is way more i'd rather watch
mano's hands of fate
it's worse than yeah i think madness is
just so
what the [ __ ] and if you want to talk
about ed wood being technically
incompetent
the dude that made manos is even more
technically incompetent they had
their camera would not do sync sound the
camera would only record 30 seconds at a
time
i think so a lot of times you have these
scenes where like the person that's
talking
there's like a person talking but
there's no audio talking but there's no
audio or
or the person that's not talking like
the other person in the conversation is
on camera but the other voice is coming
from off camera it's so bizarre the
thing about
manos is that it's so crude and so
[ __ ] up that it you kind of become
kind of mesmerized
it's kind of hypnotic yeah because it's
just like
it becomes almost artistic it's like it
was done on purpose but it wasn't
i think that's why people still remember
it and why it's one of the most
i mean i think mystery science theater
had a huge um
you know it had a lot to do with that
because they kind of dug out this
forgotten movie and put it on there and
then it
kind of introduced it to a whole new
audience yeah but there is something and
oracle just said it has a good story
buried deep deep deep in there
yeah it is actually a really good idea
for a story if somebody made this with
some technical competence it might be
really really creepy
um because you know with the whole cult
thing and all that kind of [ __ ] you
could do that and it would be really
creepy but i feel like
well it was creepy it's even creepy the
way it is as bad as it is
just because that's incompetent it's
like watching them
a snuff flick kinda or someone a crime
scene photo
well yeah and like i said i think that
when
when they did it on msc the first time i
think joel summed it up like the best
when he said every frame of this movie
looks like
someone's last known photograph that's
exactly what the [ __ ] movie looks
like
real you're not sure if you're you're
not sure if this thing is taking the
piss or not
you know what i mean yeah are they
serious they can't be serious
no i think they're serious because
they're trying to pass this off as a
movie it's like kind of [ __ ]
and some stuff i feel like it didn't
translate because the person like the
character of torgo yeah they didn't
translate at all his legs
yeah his legs he just looked like he had
big giant knees he was supposed to have
goat legs yeah you couldn't see that
though but you couldn't see him because
he had pants on obviously but they
didn't have the money to make
him have goat eggs so they stuffed his
pants full of bunches and if you had
goat legs if you had goat legs and you
were looking for victims then yeah you
would have to wear pants over the goat
legs because obviously if somebody saw
some goat-legged [ __ ] coming at
you
and i feel i feel so bad because that
dude like committed suicide not too long
after that yeah he was gay
this game's gay yeah i don't know i know
some people have said oh it's because
the movie was so terrible i don't think
i don't think the movie had anything to
do with it
i think [ __ ] with him about being gay
yeah i think he had other uh
emotional issues which is like i said
it's really really sad i'm i actually um
the dude that made manos uh he's dead
now but um
he his daughter is still on uh facebook
and she makes cloaks like those black
cloaks with the red hands on them she
makes those and sells them
on etsy yeah she's she's she seems like
a lovely person he's one that told me
that the guy who played torgo was that
was gay his dad kept [ __ ] with it oh
okay yeah yeah so that's why
yeah i knew i'd heard it from somewhere
yeah i told you when i was talking to
her
but she seemed like she tried to sell me
the movies and uh no thanks
because they have a remastered version
yeah that's most remastered
she unfortunate i don't know what she's
talking about
okay but she thinks it's a great movie
it's well it's not great in the way she
thinks it is no the thing about it and
you know this comes back to ed wood
again it's like
his movies are terrible but people are
still talking about them and they're
still entertained by them so
you can't really say that they're
terrible because they're still
entertaining right
like i said to me like the worst thing
that a movie can be is boring
yeah you know what i mean just don't be
boring if it's going to be bad at least
be so bad that people just want to like
[ __ ] get drunk and watch the [ __ ]
because it's funny as hell
you know what i'm saying um so i think
that that's kind of why and that's kind
of what happened with the ed woodwinds
and why they've
endured i think is because i think to a
degree
he thought that he was making a decent
movie well you know what though they're
the iconic low-budget
50s monster movie yeah i mean when i was
thinking of that
when you think of a low-budget 50s
monster movie
i would think of a certain damn vibe and
it ends up being some memories that i
had of
seeing growing up seeing an ed wood
movie now
if you having never seen an edward movie
will you enjoy this yeah you would
because i at the time i first saw this
movie
i only vaguely remembered edward movies
i couldn't remember any of the stories
but i
remembered the movies they were talking
about yeah like the titles
and like certain scenes you know like
them walking through the graveyard with
tor johnson and
i remember those yeah i couldn't tell
you what that movie was about
so no you don't have to see the movie
edward movies i'm still not even really
sure
the most important part of those movies
and the most
memorable elements in those movies are
shown reenacted in this movie
yeah you know yeah all of this all this
stuff from plan nine like you get with
the airplane like yeah lego see fighting
the
octopus yeah you know that's shawn that
was right that was from part of the
monster yeah
they reenact that in this so the most
memorable [ __ ] from edwards movies is
actually kind of [ __ ]
reenacted and discussed the backstory of
everything you know it's right there
in the movie so it's good it's kind of
fun to watch
this to watch ed wood and then watch the
actual movie so the kids because they're
fairly accurate i mean they did kind of
like you know fancy them up a little bit
for the movie but
from what i remember because i feel like
i've seen plan 9 from outer space
probably a couple dozen times
i've seen bride of the monster probably
about 20 times
um and i've seen glen or glenda a few
times too and from what i remember
the scenes are very similar yeah the
the the portrayal of melania's vampira
in the movie it works in the movie even
though that's not the way she
really was in real life but it like
she's
kind of shown as like
somebody who's not uh doesn't talk much
and is like kind of
looking down her nose at you yeah she
comes off his role kind of snotty
she's not yes snotty and doesn't speak
much that's not how she actually was
according to people that knew her
she was uh talkative real real talkative
um yeah she she really thought highly of
herself
but she was she wouldn't shut the [ __ ]
up
i got that impression i saw some uh i
saw some interviews with her when she
was older
right like before i think she's passed
away now but um and she did dress like a
goth
or jason [ __ ] she wore a [ __ ] chelsea
[ __ ] shaved her head nothing but
bangs
and she was doing that in the 50s yeah
so she was
a freakazoid for the 50s she attracted a
lot of attention and then she did
whatever she was an attention
[ __ ] [ __ ] attention
and wherever she went she was constantly
talking and talking and talking and
getting everybody to look at her um very
much
uh trying to be the center of attention
wherever she went
so she wasn't this kind of reclusive
solemn [ __ ]
[Music]
her and she [ __ ] stalked him for a
long time
um you know the the problem with mayla
is uh
she couldn't act she she couldn't act
and you know so she didn't really get to
she didn't get any parts
yeah i mean she was good as a horror
host yeah but she couldn't act
um you know yeah i kind of feel like
when we're talking about
because the um dolores fuller who is
played by uh sarah jessica parker in
this movie
who was um ed's first uh ed's girlfriend
when he was writing glen or glenda they
kind of um
the actual dolores fuller who was
actually quite successful and
actually even when she was in the early
50s when she was with ed
she was on like the dinah shore show and
[ __ ] like that and then later on she
went and became like a
songwriter she wrote some [ __ ] for elvis
and whatnot um
so they kind of portray her a little bit
negatively in this movie i feel like
she's kind of
seen a little bit of [ __ ] but i feel
like she's [ __ ] but she's justifiably
[ __ ]
you know what i mean because she does do
a lot of work for him and
um you know he's not getting anywhere so
she's getting frustrated
um you know and he does write her parts
and all this other kind of stuff
so i kind of feel like they did talk to
the actual dolores fuller
and she said well that's not what i was
like
but she liked the movie anyway she's
like even though it wasn't accurate
well i think they wanted to give the
characters some
personalities that could play off of one
another in a yeah
in a cinematic and i think she got that
she was like you know that's not really
what
i was like as a person and that's you
know but
i but i do i really do like the whole
scene where
um you know because he had cast her
he was going to cast her in uh you know
bride of the monster which called
brighter that adam then
so she was going to be like the main
character and then
he didn't have the money for the movie
so he meets this other woman
loretta king like in a bar or something
and he thinks
uh erroneously as it turns out that
she's some kind of heiress that she has
all this money and he's like oh i can
talk her into
you know funding the movie and she's
like well i have to be
you know the lead role so he's like okay
thinking that she's gonna put up
like 60 000 or something like that but
then
so then like him and um him and uh
delores get into this huge fight because
she was supposed to be the lead and
she's like pissed off and she got
relegated to the [ __ ] file clerk part
so that whole [ __ ] fight they had
where she like throws the [ __ ] cast
iron pan at his head and [ __ ] like that
that was like super funny and then like
it turns out too that like loretta had
like 300 bucks and that was it
like she didn't have the money and i've
actually seen so now i think of that
scene in the in ed wood every time i see
bride of the monster
because they reenact the scene like the
one scene where they're together
and it's just like so so funny i know
that's probably not exactly what
happened
but it's still funny and i still love
that
that line where he first meets her in
the bar and the waiter comes and asks
her if she wants anything and she's like
no
no liquids yeah i'm terribly allergic to
that
that liquids we assumed me and my
friends used to like quote that to each
other all the time
no liquids i'm terribly allergic to them
there's just so many [ __ ] great
god there's just so many [ __ ] great
lines in this and it's like when we were
watching it again last night it was just
like cracking up all over again
i've forgotten how much i love this
movie but yeah so if you haven't seen it
you really really need to see it and go
watch some ed
edward movies too because those are
super interesting yeah ed wood
this movie it's a masterpiece yeah it's
fantastic it's it's so
funny it's just it's beautiful to look
at say probably one of tim burton's best
movies
yeah i would argue because i think when
we were doing the beetlejuice review i
think i said oh this is
you know beetlejuice is probably my
favorite tim burton movie but i don't
know now that i'm watching edward again
i'm like
i think it's even better than mars
attacks i think it's yeah
we need to watch mars attacks again i
think that's on youtube for free
there's just something about there's
just something about ed wood it's just
more informative more memorable
more cultural it's just more cultural
significance you know what i mean
because it's talking about a guy who
really lived and
what his life was like and certain
characters you know hollywood people
hollywood characters what they were like
and it's just and
this movie will stand the test of time
and i really really love because i
really love old hollywood [ __ ] and i
love
you know like 50s yeah you know old 50s
horror movies and like i love the old
you know universal
movies so this is kind of like right in
my wheelhouse you know what i mean like
this kind of stuff
so yeah what oh no no i'm just i'm
taking a breath i can't breathe
no you can't can't breathe no i thought
you were gonna say something else yeah
you seemed like you were probably
another one that kind of
reminded me of this just because i don't
know the tone and
it being black and white would be the
loved one
we really need to we need to do that one
i need i'm going to write it down so i
can remember
that shit's expensive yeah i think the
blu-ray was like uh
40 bucks last year so it's not where you
can't stream it or anything
can we stretch it i want to own it oh
okay i want to own it that's a [ __ ]
classic
i'm just saying like for review purposes
maybe we could stream it it's a
forgotten movie
people don't know that i hadn't even
heard of it and i'm like way more into
movie [ __ ] than it's the only movie i
was able to show her she's like how i
didn't know about this movie yeah it
just completely
movies goth as [ __ ] so
early 60s black and white yeah jonathan
winters
yeah a bunch of people are in it about
this girl that
she's [ __ ] this guy meets this chick
because she's as hot as [ __ ] she's like
this weird god chick that works in a
damn cemetery she works she's a beaut
she's a beautician in a mortuary
yes she likes me yeah and he gets into
this relationship with her
and he ends up falling into this [ __ ]
into the funeral business
in a theme park cemetery yeah it's like
a dark comedy
yeah and he just finds out how weird
these [ __ ] are that run this damn
cemetery
and how it looks it links in with hot
the government
and [ __ ] the space race and [ __ ]
which is
weird [ __ ] man funny it is it's a super
it's super weird
and like i said we i do kind of feel
like it's forgotten about it
because it's a very very strange and she
lived on that member and she he goes to
her house and she lived in one of those
[ __ ] hollywood houses
on the side of a [ __ ] hill and it's
[ __ ] teetering getting ready to
collapse and slide down the hill
and she's [ __ ] swinging off the bench
and the [ __ ] house is going
whoa whoa and she's totally just
blissfully unaware
of this [ __ ] house falling and then
she's actually and it turns out she's
like
she she kind of likes the thrill that it
could fall at any minute
yes it was just weird weird movie it's a
daredevil
yeah there was a lot of weird movies
back in the day that i kind of feel like
are forgotten a little bit yeah because
i was thinking
for some reason i was just thinking of
one that i watched the other day i think
it's on to be called spider baby
yeah that had [ __ ] lon chaney jr i
feel like launch any junior was in it
then the head
the head mortician lives with his mama
who's [ __ ] super overweight remember
he feeds her
yeah that's right and he and he was
singing and [ __ ] and singing and dancing
for her and [ __ ] like it was just weird
it's a weird ass movie but like it's a
dark comedy it's kind of reminded me of
um
like doctor strange level yeah like like
that kind of that kind of vibe
like dr strangelove and [ __ ] ed wood
kind of mixed together
yeah sorta sorta yeah yeah with a little
bit of uh
heralded mod yeah mixed in there
i'm gonna review that one too i love
that book a movie there's a no i'm gonna
look for the loved one we'll see if i
can order it yeah we'll see if we can we
can every time i saw it they wanted 40
bucks for that thing because it's a rare
movie
yeah because like i said it's like it
seems like you don't really hear that
many people talking about it anymore
forgotten flick which is kind of sad
because it was really a real hybrid
movie and it's looking really well
written yeah oh well what are you gonna
do yeah maybe we can bring it back into
prominence
yeah one of these days i doubt it we'll
find ten thousand followers a million
maybe yeah but if
every single one of those ten thousand
followers just told somebody else about
it that's the loved one
yeah may not have the same cultural
impact on these youngsters i don't know
that's true that that they're like that
[ __ ] may have sailed yeah oh well just
some weird [ __ ]
all right so uh i guess ma'am we've been
going on for more than an hour
and we mostly talked about ed wood the
whole time i'm proud of us
all right so that was a show a show is a
show
so today's tuesday so tomorrow uh
wednesday is the party stream oh [ __ ]
yeah
oh [ __ ] why did why are you saying like
that go get get some [ __ ] mixers
oh yeah we still got booze right yeah
yeah
i need some more uh coconut every every
week we gotta go get
to go to the liquor store turn my liver
up
[Laughter]
it's okay that i could use the drink
yeah actually i could drink use a drink
right now it's a little bit early it's
only four o'clock in the afternoon i'll
have a drink later
all right so we will see you guys
tomorrow evening for the wednesday party
stream at 5 p.m eastern standard time as
usual
and uh thanks everybody for dropping by
as always have a good rest of your day
bye